Yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour l'épisode 4 de Subnautica
j'ai trop bien articulé ça voulait rien dire.
On sait pas trop si j'ai dit "yo tout le monde c'est Squeezie" ou si j'ai dit "la table est ronde c'est easy"
Nul !
Les amis on saute en 3 6 dans l'eau Pourquoi ? Parce que ca fait déja 1 heure je suis sur le jeu
effectivement ma sauvegarde avait été supprimée. Ça fait toujours plaisir.
Du coup j'ai farmé comme un gros fils de pute, juste pour avoir ceci : voilà et la combinaison
anti-radiation, qu'on avait mis tout un épisode à choper.
Alors là, on a un objectif extrêmement simple, on veut construire la baie à véhicule,
vous savez, qui permet de construire les vaisseaux sous-marins dans lesquels
on peut aller hyper profond et rencontrer des créatures hyper vilaines.
Le fait est que maintenant, il faut scanner des espèces de blocs pour pouvoir construire la baie
à véhicule mobile. Du coup, oui, vous l'avez deviné, on va essayer de trou-
......
Ah mais lui il fait rien, il est pourri c'est vrai...
Du coup on va essayer de trouver ces putains de blocs.
Voilà. Et il y a une signature thermique là-bas qui a été repérée et je sais pas ce que c'est
j'ai drôlement envie d'y aller.
Seulement, sans vaisseau, on va crever...
C'est sûr.
Donc on en est là. Voilà, si vous voyez un bloc vous me le dites dans le coin de l'oreille,
regardez je retire une oreille comme ça je vous entendrai, il n'y a pas de soucis
Y.O.L.O. Exploration totale.
J'ai deux piles pour recharger le Seagway. Voilà on va l’appeler le Seagway.
Petit jeu de mots sea ça veut dire mer, c'est fantas-
OH Y A DES BLOCS !
Là ici y a des trucs à scanner mon gars, c'est sûr. Regardez.
Euh, ça, non ? Ça...? Non ?
Y a pas un truc à scanner mon gars ? S'il-vous-plaît !
On veut la baie à véhicules
P*tain y a rien c'était un piège, un guet-apens.
Ca ressemble à des frigos les blocs
On dirait des frigos, des gros frigos
Et lui on peut le scanner vous pensez ?
Es ce qu'on lui manque de respect on le scanne ?
Oh oui *rire*
Ha c'est génial !
Comment on lui manque de respect quoi cette pauvre bête !
Alors il y a aussi un trucs dans cette game assez fantastique c'est que, y a zéro minerai !
Y a pas un putain de minerai mon gars
Mais vraiment.
Ah, peut être qu'il y a quelque chose à scanner ici, attention...
Oh oui ça ! Ça ça se scanne, ça ?
Équipement de laboratoire.
J'men bats les couilles
Ah ! Ça ça permet de respirer, je savais pas
C'est nouveau ça !
Merci le corail cerveau !
Fantastique ! Je sais pas qui a inventer le corail cerveau mais putain, il avait un gros cerveau.
Ça, ça se scanne ça !
Poubelle, mais je m'en fout des poubelles, j..j..je- osef !
Oh ! Il se passe quoi là ?!
What the fuck ?!
Qui souffle comme ça ?
Oh ! Mais ça fait du feu !
Hé, mais ça blague pas mon gars !
Là il y a du minerai là.
Ah c'est un cratère...
On peut pas, il y a pas un truc hyper rare à ramasser ?
Genre de la.. de la.. aaaaah
Ok je me tire, je me tire c'est un volcan sous-marin heuuu ça dégage.
Nan mais c'est pas possible que il y ait
0 fragments de machin a analysé et 0 minerais les gars.
Tout le monde voulait un nouvel épisode sur subnautica, bah regardez !
Il y a pas de minerais dans cette grotte, ça c'est une grotte a minerais ça, hein...
*reniffle*
Pourquoi il y a pas de minerais ici ? Bah parce qu'on est dans une game de merde...
*Musique sous marine*
Ecoutez, après vingt minutes de recherche qui n'ont abouties à rien du tout
j'suis tombé sur ce site qui te donne l'endroit ou il faut aller chercher les fragments a scanner,
pour construire tel ou tel truc
faut qu'on trouve huit fragments total
trois pour construire la baie de véhicule et cinq pour construire le seamoth
Ceux-là ils sont a la kelp forest et les autres aux grassy plateaus.
Il me semble que c'est ici, voila je sais qui en a deux, il y en a une la, une un peux plus loin, on va voir
on va chercher, on va chercher, on va chercher
C'est ça regarder ! Attend mec, on reconnait la.
Je partirais pas d'ici tant que je n'aurais pas trouver ces p*tains de fragments.
Attend mais c'est impossible de trouver ces fragments la...
C'était pas si dur avant de construire des véhicules mon gars...
Bon bah écoutez vous savez quoi, on va-
En fait y'a deux endroits où il y a des fougères là, comme là bas.
Y'avait là où on était et y'en a vers ici.
On va aller à celles ici
Et si on trouve pas... YOLO
*musique sous marine*
Oh mon dieu
Alors là
Fragment de baie à vé...
OH MON DIEU !
OH MON DIEU ! Je chiale !
Plus que deux.
Oh !
OH MON DIEU !
Non fragment de base de bioréacteur ça on s'en fou.
OH !
OOOOOOH !
ALORS LA !
C'est le Graal ! Et je ne parle pas de la dernière chanson de KYO.
Oh mon gars !
*rire*
J'ai envie de faire la fin de la vidéo là dessus tellement c'est le moment le plus épique de la vidéo !
Juste au moment ou on a trouvé le craft pour faire ce qu'on veut faire depuis 10 heures !
Aller on retourne à la base on va voir ce qu'il nous faut pour faire la baie à véhicule !
Et ensuite il va falloir trouver les 5 fragments pour FAIRE le véh... Holala
Alors ! Pour la faire il nous faut... Elle est ou ?
Un lingot de Titane, du lubrifiant et une batterie haute capacité.
Le lubrifiant on l'a ! Me demandez pas pourquoi...
Et le lingot de Titane, on l'a aussi !
Regardez on le fait maintenant.
On le fait maintenant hein! Ça t'en bouche un coin mon c*n!
Allez hop c'est parti on enchaine! *clap clap clap*
Et quand je disais qu'on l'avait c'est pas une blague,
regardez j'avais fait des petits stocks avant de.. de tourner.
Et ouais c'est ça de suivre un youtuber exceptionnel.
*rire*
Baie à véhicules mobiles et bah voilà ! On y arrive !
Attend c'est 10 fois plus dur qu'avant mec, hein, de construire des choses, hein.
"Déployer la baie". Déjà tu me dis pas ce que je dois faire .
Déploie toi !
Waw!
Elle est juste a coté " missing blueprint "
Ca veut dire qu'on n'a pas encore scanner les 5 fameux frangments
clap clap clap c'est parti.. .
je sais où c'est,  je sais où c'est, Papa où t'es? Pourquoi je dis ça ?
Mais avant, en fait, on va manquer d'oxygène
donc ce qui va falloir qu'on fasse c'est extrêmement simple,
c'est construire un truc nouveau (je sais pas ce que ça donne)
soit faire les fameux tuyaux de merde qu'on avait fait là, un peu pourri
soit faire la poche d'air.
Qu'est ce que c'est ? Je suis sûr c'est une grosse connerie, non ?
Poche d'air, je l'ai là. Là je fais clique droit, ça me fait remonter à la surface
mais c'est fantastique, mais ça fallait le dire avant !
bon donc ça c'est fait et avec ça on va essayer de choper
euh moi ce que je, je veux c'est le Fil d'Ariane.
"Se fixe à un point physique et se déroule pendant que vous explorez".
OK, on va faire ça. On va crafter le Fil d'Ariane
et on va l'attacher à la baie à véhicules mobile.
Super plan
*halètements d'effort*
Ouais ça c'est moi qui coupe la vigne
OK, OK les amis on est bons.
Ah non j'ai pris des graines c'est des échantillons qu'il faut...
Putain... c'est relou !
Arrêtez de vous plaindre !
*halètements d'efforts*
OK. Alors là me dites pas que je peux pas faire ce putain de fil  ou je vais péter un cable
Oui Monsieur... Ok on va ramasser notre baie.
On peut pas la prendre. Je peux pas la prendre ?
Mais naan... Bon c'est pas grave. Écoutez on va prendre ça.
Voila on a pris, on a pris une caisse on l'attachera à l'armoire imperméable.
Toujours une solution de secours et ouais. Faut être bricoleur dans Subnautica.
Donc là, c'est là où on était tout à l'heure ; on est tombé sur vraiment ce qu'on peut appeler un p*tain de miracle
Mais je crois que c'est juste après cette zone, la zone beaucoup plus profonde.
Où il y a les espèce de trucs bleus... le lithium tout ça la
Voila je pense que c'est par là. C'est là ou pas ??
Allô ??
Là-bas je vois de débris. C'est là ??
Dites moi que c'est là
*Musique sous-marine*
Les amis j'suis un peu ... fatigué. Pourquoi fatigué ?
Parce que j'ai l’impression que dans ma game il y a aucun p*tain de minerais
Et ça *rire* Le problème c'est que sans cuivre hein euh on peut pas faire euh
on peut pas faire...
d'objet qui émet de la lumière.
Que ce soit pour charger ce p*tain de truc ou cette lampe torche.
Du coup la nuit je suis bloqué, je suis juste en position foetale
dans un coin et je ne peux rien faire.
Sans déconner ça fait UUUNE heure, une heure que je nage mon gars.
Ca fait une heure que je cherche la zone.
J'suis en PLS.
*musique sous marine*
Ok, peut-être que c'est par là mec.
C'est une des rares zones que j'ai pas explorées.
On va voir ça ensemble.
Et si c'est par là, mon gars, on hurle de joie.
Oh putain ça doit être par là.
En fait la zone on la reconnaîtra, parce qu'il y a
des sortes de cheveux par terre.
Le sol a des cheveux.
Oh oui !
OH OUI !
Oh oui y'a un début de cheveux là mon gars !
Oh oui, on y est, c'est là.
Le truc c'est que c'est entre 60 et 120 mètres,
ça va être chaud,
on va avoir très peu de temps pour trouver mais on va trouver mon gars !
Clic droit pour fixer ça au sol.
Hop !
Et ça sert à quoi ?
J'ai pas trop compris à quoi ça sert
mais on va quand même l'utiliser.
C'est là. Putain c'est formidable on a trouvé.
On va sauvegarder immédiatement !
Aller y'a plus qu'a trouver le spot où y'a plein de frigos.
Et là mon pote on est les rois !
Aller va bien y avoir un truc sans déconner !
Mais nan ! Sans mentir !
Excuse-moi !
Est-ce que t'aurais pas vu un putain de...
Tu sais de....frigo ?
Genre Samsung ou Bosch ou Siemens ?
Nan ?
J'en ai marre.
On est tellement profonds !
Allé elle est où l'entrée ?
Y'a une entrée. Ne me mentez pas je le sais !
Putain...
Sans déconner...
Où est cette entrée bordel de merde ?
Mais là on va manquer, on va crever.
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est quoi ?
Ok j'ai ouvert ça et ça fait quoi ?
Encore une autre porte ?
Putain mais y'a rien !
J'ai plus d'air à force d'ouvrir des portes !
Ah c'est tout ! Y'avait rien, c'était un leurre !
Si je puis me permettre, c'est faux. J'ai trouvé un peu de cuivre donc maintenant on a des piles dans notre seaglide.
On va un peu plus vite.
Mes amis aujourd'hui est un grand jour, puisqu'enfin...
le seamot...
vient de finir...
sa construction...
Et on a, un putain, de sous-marin !
Après, 1h30, 2h (que dis-je!?) d'explora-
AAAAAAH !
J'suis déjà en train de le casser !
Putain de merde !
Bref ! On est pas mal...
47% !? Mais attend il est en plastique le seamot !
Du coup on va voir ce qu'il y avait à la signature thermique là-bas.
Est-ce un volcan ? Est-ce autre chose ? On ne sait pas.
Aïe.
Aïe. Aïe !
C'est une blague ?
Voilà !
Ce qui reste de notre...
*pleure*
Bon voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo
sur subnautica !
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu !
Écoutez le jeu à bien changé. Y'a beaucoup plus de trucs qu'avant.
Mais je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué maintenant que tu dois scanner des fragments
pour construire quoique ce soit.
Par exemple pour construire des trucs qui...qui fait spawn des véhicules.
Et bah il faut trouver cinq fragments qui sont hyper profonds,
donc ut peux pas y aller avec un véhicule puisque du coup,
et bah t'as pas encore scanné les fragments
Enfin bref.
Ouh j'étais très fébrile sur cette explication.
Du coup on voit qu'ils mettent l'exploration en avant
et qu'ils rendent le truc un petit peu plus dur.
Mais je trouve ça pas forcément génial.
Enfin bon, le jeu est quand même très très bon.
On va pas se mentir.
Et on a construit le seamot. A partir de là tout va bien !
A très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez-vous bien, ciao tout le monde !
Peace !
*musique*